there's very little inside information
when it comes to the future of aaron
rodgers
i think he knows what he's going to do
and i think he's going to show up
next week and i think one of the reasons
he's been coy about it
is mark murphy the ceo of the team
meets with shareholders slash
cheeseheads
slash fans of the team at lambeau field
next monday
for the annual shareholder meeting why
would aaron rodgers
want to give all those fans
a reason to exhale in their knowledge
that aaron rodgers is showing up the
very next day
for the start of camp let murphy sweat i
mean ultimately murphy's the guy that
rogers has a problem with
brian gouda kunst is the name that
surfaced early on
once rogers let it be known that he
wanted out but murphy's the guy who
number one is the ceo and number two as
of a few years ago
when goodacous became the gm and mike
mccarthy was still the coach
murphy got more involved in the football
operation there's no way
murphy didn't sign off on the trade up
to get jordan love and i think at some
level
murphy tries to manipulate aaron rodgers
i think murphy was happy about tyler
dunn's story in early
2020 2019 excuse me i'm getting my ears
a little bit screwy here but it was 2019
the first year with matt lafleur
all the dirty laundry came out about
mccarthy and rogers and
murphy's attitude was basically hey if
this pisses some people off
good maybe people will be more motivated
to come out and have a big 2019 season
and they did and then last year the
drafting of jordan love
pissed off aaron rodgers what happens
he's the mvp
now the question is what will they do
when he shows up this year and i
still believe that murphy would rather
move on with jordan love
murphy would rather aaron rodgers not
show up you know if he doesn't show up
they they avoid 14.9 million in salary
assuming he doesn't show up at all this
year
they can collect 11.5 million in
unearned
signing bonus money and there's another
6.8 million that's available
in a roster bonus that he's earned but
they won't have to pay him and you look
at their balance sheets they lost like
38 million last year well they'll make
back 35 million of it or thereabouts
if rogers just doesn't show up i think
murphy would prefer he doesn't
if he does that could be the moment that
the door
opens for a potential trade because it
could be that psychologically
the packers at the top of the
organization don't
want to have the aaron rodgers farewell
tour
usually you see a farewell tour under
circumstances where
the guy is going to ride off into the
sunset with a gold watch
and he's not going to play for anybody
else and i know that we saw that a
little bit differently with brady
two years ago but with tom brady no one
really knew with certainty he was
leaving the patriots
it started to become a little more
obvious as the season progressed but it
wasn't something that
that hovered so conspicuously over the
franchise
from the first day of camp if rogers
reports
on the first day that cloud is going to
hang over green bay
until the end of the season this idea
that he's done
after this year and yeah hey look maybe
they can push the buttons and pull the
cords in a way that
gets aaron rodgers sufficiently pissed
off that he takes the package to the
super bowl and wins it
but along the way man it's going to be a
long
year for mark murphy it's going to be a
long year for brian goodkin so it's
going to be a long year from outlaw
who's going to be caught in the middle
between the lingering animosity you know
if aaron rodgers shows up it's not going
to be like
russell wilson in seattle who has
completely slammed the door
on the things that were bothering him
back in
february and march he's been able to
move on from it completely and he's all
in
and maybe he'll be all out again after
this season but for now he's
all in i think when roger shows up he
may try to say he's all in he's not
going to be all in he's said too much
too much has been reported too much has
been discussed
he's not happy with the upper levels of
the organization
that's not going to go away he's going
to be asked about it he's going to talk
about it it's going to constantly be
there and that's why i think
that in a weird sort of way if he wants
to be traded
showing up may be the first step toward
getting
the executive level of the organization
to
say we think that it's in the best
interest of the team to move on to
jordan love
look aaron rodgers didn't show up for
any of the off-season program he skipped
the mandatory mini camp he's
he's thinner than he needs to be he
hasn't worked out with any of his
teammates in months
we got a guy who's been working and
working and grinding and ready
and we believed in him enough to trade
up in round one to get him in april of
2020 let's go with him
so don't be shocked if he shows up and
showing up
is the first domino in the path that
results in rogers being traded to the
broncos at some point by the middle of
august i'm not saying it's going to
happen
but i'm saying that it's something that
we need to pay attention to rogers
showing up for camp is not by any means
the end of the story it's the beginning
of a new chapter and it's going to be
the gift it keeps on giving
all year long at least until he's traded
and if he's traded
then it takes on a new level altogether
with
the new team becoming a focal point and
the packers becoming even more
interesting to see what they can do
without rogers on the field
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports